Master Wayne well Imaging is showing me  two dozen hostiles on the third floor  why don't I drop you off on the second  I'm getting slow in my old age effort  even you got to hold die young not a  lack of trying  he has the power to wipe out the entire  human race and we believe there's even a  1% chance that he is our enemy we have  to take it as an absolute sir  the greatest gladiator match in the  history of the world God versus man  day versus night you're psychotic it's a  three syllable word for any thought too  big for little minds  but now a few women like you  whoo I don't think you've ever known a  woman like me  you know the oldest lie in America  but power can be innocent  you  you